welcome to another Q&A episode of the
stronger by science podcast in today's
episode Greg and I answer listeners
questions about fasted training peaking
for powerlifting meets recovering from a
diet training frequency and much more to
finish off the episode Greg and I
discuss how much evidence we need to see
before we start implementing a new
strategy into our own training or
coaching if you want your questions
answered on a future episode be sure to
go to tiny dot CC slash SBS QA or you
can click on the link in the episode
description as always thank you for
listening and enjoy the show welcome
back to the stronger by science podcast
this is your host Eric Traxler I'm
joined today by my temporary guest host
Greg knuckles thanks for having me back
on absolutely so before we get into the
questions and the answers today because
it is a Q&A episode I do want to briefly
make an announcement here sneak peek for
next week's episode next week we have a
great interview with Alex Colley Ari
Turner he is working on a PhD over in
the UK and he's currently recruiting
subjects for his study and it is an
extremely cool study so he wanted to
help him out with recruitment now his
project is going to teach us a lot about
muscle memory and more specifically he's
interested in looking at how muscle my
own nuclei numbers change when people
use steroids and if those changes revert
back to normal after they stop using so
what they're looking for are people who
are either current or past steroid users
totally non-judgmental totally
confidential and in many cases they're
able to cover your travel your travel
costs if you're traveling within Europe
and they will cover your travel costs if
you're within the UK absolutely so the
reason we're mentioning this is for
their 2019 round of data collection
their final data collection dates are
October 26 through 28th so these are the
last opportunities for current and past
steroid users living within Europe to
get involved in 2019 now they will be
doing some sampling in 2020 so even if
you can't make though
October dates you'll still want to get
in touch with Alex and and the way to
get in touch with him is using the email
address in the episode description so if
you're interested if you think you might
qualify shoot Alex an email and see what
he has to say and if that's too much
trouble you can just message me on
Facebook or Instagram and I can put you
in touch with Alex yeah you can message
Greg about this you cannot message me
about keeping Greg on as some type of
permanent co-host cuz that's just not
going to happen you can and you should
absolutely message Erik about that and
in fact you should probably do so
multiple times a day note those messages
do a lot more harm than good as I've
said many many times alright so let's go
ahead and get into this Q&A episode
question we're kicking off with is for
Eric Eric again to be clear Trexler not
Helm's Eric does is there any reason to
do fasted cardio for performance and not
for weight loss I think the assumption
behind this question being that maybe
you're producing more ketones and that
will help fuel cardio performance during
during a fasted state yeah so here we go
fasted training I didn't realize that
this there's a lot of people that are
really really really adamant about
fasted training I knew that intermittent
fasting was a big thing with a pretty
pretty enthusiastic following I didn't
know fasted training was the same way
until we made a recent Instagram post
and got some got some pushback from
fasted training nation so I very
cautiously limp into the fray with my
answer to this question hoping that no
one will be very upset now I should at
least acknowledge the fact you know
there's no conclusive evidence for a fat
loss benefit of fasted training I
understand that wasn't the question but
it is one of those things that comes up
all the time with fasted training there
are several studies looking at it it
just doesn't seem to be
special when it comes to losing weight
or losing fat in the long term now when
it comes to performance similarly there
is no conclusive benefit based on
research to training in a fasted state
there is some evidence to suggest that
it is deleterious or less beneficial to
train in the fasted State I'll get to
that in a minute
now there is some evidence if we're
trying to be like pretty fair and give a
little bit of credit where credit's due
we've talked about this on the show
before I forget what episode but there's
some evidence that there could be
benefits to training in a glycogen
depleted State however this is only if
you're doing pretty low intensity work
and typically speaking it's going to be
within a program that also includes some
high-intensity work that is done when
glycogen stores are not compromised the
the premise of the idea they'll talk
about like training low is sometimes the
terminology they use in the research but
the idea is that if you're doing low
intensity work that almost exclusively
is challenging aerobic metabolic systems
there is some evidence to suggest that
doing some of this low glycogen training
with low intensities can help help
promote increased adaptations of those
aerobic low intensity energy systems so
looking at different mitochondrial
adaptations there are some benefits
there with low glycogen training that's
not necessarily fasted training it's
just purely based on you know the
current carbohydrate availability at the
time of the bout and you could induce
low glycogen by fasting you could induce
it by you know doing a prior training
about with some degree of carbohydrate
restriction that fails to restore the
glycogen storage so it's not exactly the
same thing as fasted training now there
was a study that came out by bin not
harridan which I absolutely
mispronounced almost certainly but that
came out
2019 and what they were looking at was
the the effects of breakfast skipping on
resistance training performance over a
series of repeated sets to failure I
think they were looking at the squat and
squat and bench press is that right Greg
that seems completely plausible it was
some kind of upper body and lower body
compound lift so you know it could have
been like a chest press and a leg press
or something like that but you get the
drift I believe it was four sets to
failure for each if memory serves but
basically what they found was that
compared to having a carbohydrate rich
breakfast
the people who skip breakfast again it
was kind of an experimental thing where
they did both they did both treatments
but breakfast skipping was associated
with unfavorable outcomes they completed
less repetitions during the exercise
testing now we posted about that and
people got very upset and basically said
no these are you know the the paper did
say that this was in people who are
habitual breakfast eaters and so a lot
of people said well you can adapt to
this over time now one point of
contention I have with that is I don't
believe that there's such thing as a
breakfast skipper and on being a getting
a little bit into semantics but there
are no breakfast skippers there are late
breakfast eaters and so if you do a
study like I I think it would have made
a lot more sense if they specifically
asked people do you train before your
first calorie consumption not do you
skip breakfast because if you're a
breakfast skipper but you train after
lunch you're not adapted to fasted
training so like it's a little bit
semantics but it is an important
distinction that there's really no such
thing as a breakfast skipper there's
just late breakfast eaters so what they
really in my opinion should have been
looking at is when your first calories
are consumed in relation to your typical
training habits but anyway and to be
clear what Eric is getting at here is
that the word breakfast like it's a
two-part word break fast
you are in a fasted State after a night
of sleep whatever the first thing you
eat after that that fasted state is you
are breaking your fast and so like we
are like cultural terminology like we
call generally a morning meal breakfast
but if the first thing you eat is like
at a time that would generally be
associated with lunch and you're
breaking your fast then that it is still
a breakfast you're still breaking your
fast so it would be like both breakfast
and lunch because lunch doesn't have as
far as I'm aware like a semantic
connotation of second meal of the day so
yeah you're assuming you aren't a
breatharian you break your fast every
day you do eat breakfast every day and
may just not be a standard breakfast
times if it does bring up a good point
there's an extreme lack of research on
breatharians and and their kind of
optimal training strategies but if
you're not a breatharian and you don't
know what it is it's probably not worth
your time to look it up it's I guess
it's people who say that they just don't
eat ever right yeah they claim to get
the nourishment they need from the air
that they breathe some people say
they've been doing it for like what
seven eight years yeah it sure would be
cool to see that rigorously studied I a
metabolic ward yeah I I have to assume
they occasionally cheat on their diet
yeah
I'd love to put that IRB through for a
metabolic ward study on breatharians be
like well we're just gonna hold them in
here for six or seven years they will
not have access to food I don't think
that'll go very well well I I think a
lot of breatharians are also kind of
like hippie types and it's not just like
there's nourishment in the air but it's
more like when you go out in nature and
there's like fresh sunlight and like
vegetation around the air and those
circumstances is like particularly
nourishing and you can
live off of it so I I don't think you'd
be able to do a metabolic cord study but
you didn't you could just get like a
master student and tell them like follow
this [ __ ] around for like six
months and see if they eat anything tail
them like we got to get to the bottom of
this I think I think that's the best you
could do
Hospital air one and do it yeah yeah I
think that's the best you could do
without the breatharian community saying
like mmm big ol loophole not enough
sunlight we need we need more nourishing
sunlight up here in the mix yeah so in
any case what I'm getting at is you know
this study came out and people said well
hey that was in breakfast skippers but
it was in breakfast eaters not in people
who normally skip breakfast but that
doesn't necessarily mean they were all
adapted to training in the fasted State
it just means they didn't like eating
right out of bed okay so that's an
important distinction but in any case
you know people kept kind of we're
arguing that you could adapt to this and
I think it's one of the things you
should always ask yourself about the
ability to adapt to something is just
but just because you can does it mean
you should
and I want to be really clear if you
train fasted because it's convenient and
you like it
I am completely fine with that it causes
me no stress whatsoever and you're gonna
be fine but when I look at any number of
any person who is supposed to perform
well for a living in basically any
pursuit go to any strength room for any
sport at any college or pro team you're
not gonna find coaches saying all right
be honest who slipped up and had
breakfast before they came in don't
don't lie to me I know that you had
breakfast and if you're gonna bring that
[ __ ] into my weight room just turn
around and walk out so could you
potentially adapt to training fasted
almost certainly there's some degree of
partial adaptation maybe it's full
adaptation and your performance goes
from being acutely below normal to
pretty much normal but what's the plus
of that
adaptation I mean the only plus would be
you know you eating breakfast before
training doesn't fit your schedule maybe
if you eat before training it upsets
your stomach these are all totally fine
and I get it
and you probably will adapt at least to
some degree to fasted training but I
don't think that adapting to being able
to Train fasted is a goal that makes
sense for many people does that make
sense Gregg yeah I agree
one thing one thing I would add and Eric
kind of touched on this but I don't
think made it explicit is like this
question was specifically asking about
fasted cardio and not fasted weight
training and I think the key distinction
is just kind of what the what the
intensity of that session is going to be
so if it is a low intensity cardio
session so you know like like below
lactate threshold probably fairly long
duration but you're not you know you're
not really pushing the intensity of that
session doing it fast it is probably
fine it will probably especially if it's
longer duration it will probably
compromise performance to some degree
but again looking at the the loci Kajin
availability literature like it may
slightly compromise performance but
possibly improve adaptations and you
come out ahead or at least you're not
losing anything like you're not giving
up adaptations but if it's if it's
higher intensity stuff it's probably not
a good idea to to do that and then in a
fasted state so you know if it's above
threshold like you're doing tempo runs
or especially if you're doing a hit if
you're like considering that fasted
cardio
that's not stuff you would want to do in
a fasted state the the research on
improved adaptations with localization
availability that that has mostly been
done looking at at lower intensity
cardio and with higher intensity stuff
being
a fasted state and specifically a lower
cly Kajin state is is likely to
compromise performance to a great enough
degree that it will probably compromise
adaptations as well
so yeah like low intensity stuff fasted
is fine local I Kajin is fine higher
intensity stuff probably not a bad idea
to have some food in your system or if
you are going to do it fasted like first
thing in the morning make sure you eat a
bunch of carbs the night before so you
have enough glycogen for that higher
intensity stuff that's a good point
very clearly I used this question as a
jumping-off point to continue an
argument because I'm probably in the top
3% most petty people in the universe so
in the interest of being useful that's
an excellent point
there there are distinctions between
fasted and low glycogen training there
are distinctions between applications
for high and low intensity and
everything Gregg just said is completely
on point and here's a kind of a
practical way to do it if you're doing
low intensity cardio and there is zero
question about the amount of work that
will be performed so like let's say
you're gonna go on a treadmill on a set
speed for a set time and cover a set
distance you're gonna be fine in a
fasted state you're gonna do just as
much it's it's not the issue is when you
try to go in fasted to high-intensity
work or work is some kind of about where
the amount of work is in question and
there's potential that because you're in
a fasted state and not performing
optimally you might shortchange the
amount of work done and therefore
eventually impaired long term adaptation
from that but if it's low intensity
stuff and and you know this you know
specific amount of work is gonna get
done for a particular purpose yeah
you're you're just fine doing fasted
cardio all right moving on oh one other
thing I want to mention before we move
on I totally don't care if you train
fasted it's convenient for some people
you'll probably adapt to it at least
partially
you'll be fine if you train fasted but
most importantly I will be fine
if you train fasted so no need to get
angry at me or send mean messages do
still message him about me being a
permanent co-host though not it doesn't
help whatsoever okay we've got another
question by coin 777 the question is I
have two powerlifting meets separated
four weeks apart how do I train to be
peaked for both of them okay so so this
is a good question and it so to answer
it first off I think it's it's important
to talk about what exactly you should
expect out of a peak so one of the
things I see a mistake I see a lot of
people make is they assume they're going
to get way more out of a peak than is
actually reasonable and they're thinking
like oh man yeah if if I can if I can
grind out a 500 a 500 pound squad and
training then man when I peak and I get
those like me day nerves going and
whatnot get that adrenaline rush I'm
gonna be good for 550 like I see that
from a reasonable amount of people and
the fact is like you just shouldn't
expect that much out of a peak if you
look at the research on it and also if
you talk to most lifters it seems like
the most you should it seems like a
reasonable amount to expect out of a
properly executed peak is a roughly 2 to
4 percent improvement in performance
that that is typical there are
absolutely people who get more out of a
peak than that talking to Chad Wesley
Smith about it and I think he's written
about this for juggernaut as well in in
some of the older articles on the site
it seems like especially for his squat
he gets like 10 percent out of a good
peak and so like that is possible
but I think it's less like whether or
not I think it's less that if you
execute a properly like if you execute a
perfect peak you'll get 10% of out of it
and more that there are some people who
can get 10% out of a peak but if that
hasn't happened to you before probably
you're in the 2 to 4 percent range like
that's that standard now a quick
question when you talk about a 2 to 4
percent increase from a peak is that
basically saying if you were to test
when you're in you're like really beat
up end of training phase status and then
you kind of implement this peak of
tapering and then you retest the
difference between those is like 2 to 4%
is that what we're operating that I
think the best way to operationally
think about it is like 2 to 4% over like
a quote unquote normal state like a
normal training state so I mean maybe
it's like 5% or a little more over like
a super overreached possibly tipping
towards over trained state okay like if
you're just really really worn down and
crushed with like really high volume
training I would I would kind of argue
that if if you're seeing that if you're
doing enough volume that you're getting
that large of a decrement in performance
that you can get that big of a super
compensation from a peak you're you
might be overdoing your training in the
first place but no the 2 to 4 percent is
over like a normal non hyper fatigued
and over each state you know when I when
I did my meet in 2012 I did the base
mezzo cycle of small of but then I took
one week of just normal training and
then I did the base mezzo cycle again oh
no zone 9 or 8 out of 9 weeks was doing
base small of with a retested max in
between and yes so you know you probably
did get a pretty big boost I got like a
35%
not literally but it was big yeah yeah
so so yeah like if if you're someone who
like you play in your training into the
meet to be significantly overreached
prior to the taper and peak you may get
two to four percent or more than two to
four percent out of it I would question
whether that's smart in the first place
but anyway two to four but it's not ya
I'm being an idiot yeah two to four
percent that's that is a standard amount
to get out of a peak so I just wanted to
make that clear on the front end because
I think a lot of people roll into a meet
and they're like oh man I thought I was
gonna hit a 10 pound PR on the platform
I went for that I missed it I think I
probably could have hit a five pound PR
and the thing is like a good peak is
probably like a five pound PR a lot of
people so just in terms of evaluating
whether your Peaks were good or not I
think a lot of people expect way too
much from a good peak
anyway so the actual question itself you
have to meets four weeks apart how do
you train to be peaked for both of them
I would say it's probably not possible
to be perfectly peaked for both meets so
I think your your best bet is to try to
have one meet where you do peak properly
and one meet where you're still somewhat
peaked or at least rolling into it in a
non fatigued state but but maybe you
can't dial in every little piece of your
peak perfectly so another just general
statement is I'm going to tell you how I
would probably recommend a nondescript
person peak knowing absolutely nothing
about them and having no context one
thing that I highly highly recommend
people do is if you're planning to roll
into a meet and you're planning on
peaking for it practice speaking and
training I
think there's so like there's some
research on what tends to work well for
peeking but if you talk to good lifters
who have experimented with different
approaches to peeking for meats you're
gonna hear a fair amount of different
opinions about what has worked well for
them or not I think that certain
approaches to peeking just don't work
that well for some people and completely
different approaches work well for
different folks so sometimes it's just a
detail like how far out do you do your
last heavy training like for someone
like hitting your last heavy squat five
days out in a fairly low volume session
but still like loading pretty heavy five
days out that that may be what they find
works best for them for someone else you
know you may want to hit your heaviest
squat your lower your last heavy squat
in training ten fourteen days out so
sometimes it's just a detail like that
like when do you actually start pulling
the plug and lowering training stress
sometimes it's just the way you approach
the the D load at the end of the peak so
what you will often see recommended in
the research is to cut volume but not
necessarily drop intensity too much so
you know you probably don't want to be
doing singles at 95 percent of your max
three days before the meet but still you
know putting eighty eighty-five percent
on the bar but just you know keeping
volume fairly low cutting some sets
staying at eight RPE
or below that's what you tend to see
recommended in the literature what works
well for a lot of people though is to
drop intensity and volume and say you
know you're gonna do your last heavy
singles like you're gonna hit your
openers maybe a week out or so and then
for the week of the meet you're gonna
keep lifting but you're probably not
going to go over 65 70 percent of your
max and you're just gonna hit doubles
and triples so for some people it works
to leave the intensity higher for some
people you drop both volume and
intensity so yeah there's there's
different approaches to
that worked well for different people
for you as an individual you may find
different approaches work for different
lifts a lot of people find that they can
keep training bench a little bit harder
and loading it a little bit heavier -
closer to the meet whereas you know two
weeks out is the last time they even
think about a heavy deadlift so yeah
just as a general rule play around with
your peaking if if that's what is going
to make if that's something that you're
planning to make some sort of
substantial impact about your
performance on the platform which is
ultimately what you're training for if
you're planning on competing it doesn't
make much sense to me that that's
something that you would leave as a
complete unknown and just you know do it
and hope it works and never have
practiced it before so yeah try
different approaches to peeking in your
training and get an idea of what works
for you before you know you're two weeks
out from a meet and it's like well drew
up this peaking cycle let's just roll
the dice and hope it works so anyway I'm
going to give advice with the assumption
that you peak kind of normally but if
you know how peaking works well for you
you can just kind of like sub that
approach in to the advice I'm about to
give okay so with with that massive
preamble out of the way yeah at least
two meets if the first meet is the more
important one then what I would
recommend is for the first meet peak
normally and commit to it so you know if
that means for example you're you're
done with heavy training ten days out
and then you're just doing light stuff
rolling like rolling up to the meet for
the last ten days prior to the meet and
then you know you're you're going to go
really really hard at that meet you're
probably going to be fairly fatigued and
worn down afterwards it might take you
you know four or five days maybe up to a
week to feel normal and get back into
hard training again and then you know lo
and behold you only have two weeks of
actual training time before your next
meet you know your
probably not going to be an optimal
performance for the second meet but if
the first meet is the one that really
matters to you that's fine so if the
first meet is the important one commit
to it
peak how you normally would take the
time off after the meet like about four
or five days or up to a week because the
assumption is if that's the important
meet you're really really really going
hard at that you're trying to you know
hit the heaviest third attempt so you
possibly can you're gonna be a little
fatigued and then for the second meet
after the first meet you have a week
either off or doing really easy training
to recover then the second week so three
weeks out you're gonna have one week of
normal heavy training but at low ish RP
es so in that week you'd probably want
to go up to about 80 85 % of your max
but for all of your stuff you probably
want to leave at least two or three reps
in the tank if you're the type of person
who likes to overreach before of meet
and then try to deal owed and super
compensate to pull back don't [ __ ] try
to overreach in realistically two weeks
of training when you're just coming off
a meet would not recommend that so
you're gonna get realistically one week
of normal training a week after you're
your first meet and like I said go
fairly heavy eighty eighty-five percent
but keep our PE s relatively low try to
try to leave at least two or three reps
left in the tank and keep volume pretty
manageable as well you don't want to try
to overreach in one week that's a bad
idea then the next week you're probably
gonna be hitting openers the order I
would generally recommend to hit those
openers in is probably deadlift early in
the week somewhere close to 14 days out
from the meet squat when you're
recovered from hitting the deadlift
opener so probably somewhere in the
neighborhood of 10 days out from the
meat and then bench last probably 7 to 8
days out from the meat and then for meat
week what I would generally recommend
for the actual D load Porsche
is continuing to train get in the gym
four or five days and just stick with
like 55 to 70 percent of your max and
just do sets of like two or three do
five or six sets really easy stuff
you're mainly just trying to keep your
joints feeling good keep the movement
patterns fresh and snappy but but I'm of
the opinion that it's generally a pretty
good idea to lower both volume and
intensity but still get in the gym and
get some work done so any way you would
do that as your thie load and then you
compete at the end of that week so you
have one week all four really easy after
the first meet second week fairly heavy
but not super hard you're not gonna have
time to elicit a major training effect
so really it's just a week to to
reintroduce yourself to heavy training
after that easy week off after the meet
third week openers fourth week D load
and compete at the end of the week
you're probably not gonna do quite as
well in the second meet as the first
meet but again here I'm assuming the
first ones the important one second meet
should still go pretty okay with that
approach then if the second meet is the
one that's more important to you what I
would recommend you do is just implement
it into your training almost so for
example I would probably set up like
wave type training and so you know you
have a week that's like if you're doing
a three week wave you have a lighter
week than a moderately heavy week than a
heavy week and then you go back to a
lighter week than a moderately heavy
week and then a heavy week and so if you
have one meet that's four weeks out what
I would probably do is two weeks out
from that meet probably train at around
eighty percent one week out from that
meet I would probably hit soft openers
early in the week so you know maybe a
little below which are actually going to
open but at least hit like a kind of
heavy single early in the week and all
three of your lifts another wise
training around 85% and keep our Pease
low ish so the meats
not going to go bad like they'll still
be relatively fresh then you hit the the
meet the next week and that is the heavy
week of this block so you know if it
would be like 80 percent one week 85
percent the next week and then in normal
circumstances 90 percent the third week
realistically you're rolling up to the
meet and you're probably not going to
miss any lifts you're not going to push
it as hard as you possibly can you're
probably going to hit something that is
like you know 95 96 percent so you can
just kind of slot that in as the third
week of your wave and then after the
meet since you shouldn't be super super
worn down from that because you're not
actually hitting true maxes the week
after about 80% week after that about
85% week after that third week of the
wave pretty heavy again use that for
your openers and then you D load and
compete the following week
for the week of that first meet since
all of the heavy work that week is back
loaded you're you're going to hit
everything on Saturday at the meet I
would recommend just redistributing the
lifts that you typically do in in your
week so you know you're probably doing
stuff other than just one heavy squat
day one heavy bench day one heavy
deadlift day so I what I recommend is
still doing that other training
throughout the week but keeping our P's
fairly low so you know generally leaving
about three reps in reserve and probably
lowering volume a bit as well so
dropping probably one to two sets per
exercise below what you would typically
do and I'd probably recommend trying to
do a fair amount of that training early
in the week so for me tweak on the first
week if you generally disperse your
training throughout the week
I'd recommend trying to do kind of like
your your lighter work first squat bench
deadlift or like your accessories like
your front squats or like close grip
bench or whatever try to do most of that
stuff on like Sunday through winds
day so you can take Thursday and Friday
kind of easy and then be fairly fresh
for for a meet on Saturday and again
just using that as like your heavy
training for that third week of the wave
and then as long as in that first meet
you are taking it kind of easy you're
not hitting thirds that you might miss
you're not grinding too much
you're just generally trying to put a
solid total on the platform but not the
absolute best you're capable of you
should probably be fine to go ahead and
pick back up where you left off the next
week with with a normal week of training
to start the next way that again around
80 percent of your max give or take so
yeah that's uh that's what I would
recommend I feel like that was a pretty
long answer to that question but I think
there was a fair amount to unpack there
I mean I think that's one of those
things people can refer back to now that
we have pressed it to vinyl I think it
made sense to give a nice detailed
answer I just want to reiterate what you
said for it you said it for powerlifting
but it works for bodybuilding too if
you're going into any kind of peaking
strategy for any kind of athletic event
and you're really really pulling for
some kind of miraculous some kind of
miraculous peaking strategy that your
performance is totally going to be
predicated on it's probably a bad
strategy you know so like a lot of
bodybuilders are like so if I look
horrible seven days out what can I do
it's like well the best strategy for a
bodybuilder is like when you're 13 days
out or 11 days out you're like like be
on stage tomorrow I feel all right
I feel like powerlifting is different
but it's the same thing you're you're
you shouldn't put all of your eggs in
the basket of hoping for a last-minute
kind of miracle unless you do have a
history of that
so I mean ladies yes someone like Chad
Wesley Smith if he has a history of you
know maybe you do your first meet and
you think you're going to get four
percent out of a peak and then your
third attempt squats just an absolute
joke it's like oh maybe I get more out
of a peak you do a second meet you maybe
go
you maybe assume you're gonna get 6% out
of your peak your third attempt squad is
still a joke then it's like okay like
maybe I do get a lot out of a peak but
that's that's kind of what I was getting
at where you should practice this [ __ ]
beforehand so you know realistically
what to expect and you're not just
trying stuff on meet day cuz it does
sometimes work in Reverse like if you're
someone who does let yourself get pretty
overreached near the end of a cycle you
may get more than 2 / 2 to 4 percent out
of a peak and you don't want to assume
that you are only going to get a little
bit and then lowball all of your
attempts so yeah that's the just
practice this and base it on base it on
prior experience and if if you're
rolling into a meet and you don't have
any prior experience of peeking to base
your expectations on like that's that's
your problem but but if you've
historically not gotten 10% out of a
peak like treks was saying and you're
thinking well maybe this is the time
it's not going to be the time your your
past peaking experience is probably
going to be fairly indicative of what
you're going to get out of it in the
future and that that's a key distinction
as well between the the two different
you know bodybuilding and powerlifting
with bodybuilding you're going to show
up you're going to try to look your best
period with powerlifting huh you have to
actually select your attempts so so as
you were saying like you have to have
some idea to make sure not just that
you're overshooting your attempts but
also that you're not under shooting them
because they're equally not great
absolutely alright next question for
Eric from Gon's and oak how long how
long does it take metabolically to
recover from long-duration diets so for
example a show prep that you have to
push for a great number of months so I
feel like every question we get we start
with like a list of caveats but this
isn't just
for bodybuilding competitors you know
people go on diets for a variety of
reasons and the the goals of those diets
are certainly quite different but I
think because there's a lot of content
out there about recovering from really
intense prep diets that people have I'm
not saying that the person asking this
question is but I seen a lot of people
who are like okay so I dieted for six
months how do I recover from this but
what you find is it was six months of a
very very chill diet wasn't a super fast
rate of weight loss they didn't get
super lean and they did not lose that
much weight doesn't mean their diet
didn't work it means they took a very
conservative approach and they got to a
healthy body weight that is good so but
but what I'm getting at is recovery from
a diet depends on how long was it how it
how extreme was the rate of weight loss
and it essentially how lean did you get
at the end and also what was the the
total magnitude of weight loss so even
if you didn't get exceptionally lean you
might be in an interesting physiological
state if you just lost a hundred pounds
at the same time you know you might be
in a super interesting state if you
didn't necessarily lose that much weight
but you went from sustainably lean to
unsustainably lean for a photoshoot or
competition or whatever for your wedding
who you know people diet for all sorts
of reasons so the the general premise
there is that the recovery duration
because the question is how long does it
take the recovery duration depends on
how extreme the diet was and we also
have to consider what the word recovery
entails so a lot of people wonder if my
metabolic rate or my energy expenditure
energy expenditure seems low if my
energy expenditure seems low how long
will it take for that to go back to
normal
sometimes people say hey my testosterone
is low when is that going to recover I'm
not performing well in the gym when is
that going to recover
I have no libido or I've been missing my
periods or I can't sleep at night or I'm
extremely hungry there are many
different facets of recovery
that all seemed to recover on slightly
different timescales and one of the
critical things determining that time
scale is how much you actually commit to
recovering so I'm gonna for this
question I'm gonna assume that you you
dieted to an extreme enough level that
recovery is needed which again is not
everybody if you're at a sustainable
body weight and you took a conservative
approach to dieting you probably don't
need to recover at all really but let's
say you do need to recover you know
you're you're in this state where energy
expenditure is low your hormones are a
mess your performance sucks you have no
libido all that stuff the rate of your
recovery is going to be predicated
largely on how much you overfeed and to
some degree the regain of weight is
probably going to drive some of this
recovery how much weight do you need to
regain it really depends on what a good
sustainable non dieting body fat is for
you you know not everyone has the same
minimum body fat level they can that
they can comfortably maintain but you
got to kind of play with it and figure
out what that is but I can tell you that
if your body is typically nice and
comfortable and things are great at 13
percent body fat as a male and you're
trying to hang around at 6 percent for a
while your recovery could essentially
just not happen I mean if you you can
basically just keep yourself in that
state if you don't commit to actually
increasing your energy intake putting a
little bit of weight back on and really
prioritizing that recovery so what we
can do is we can look at studies that
have looked at this recovery in people
that have done bodybuilding or physique
related preps and there there's a few
case studies there is a really nice
study by you haha me and his colleagues
over in Finland where they actually had
a decent sized sample of females that
that did a prep and a recovery when we
look at the at this data or this body of
research as a whole the hormones that
are associated with short term energy
availability so looking at things like
ghrelin and thyroid hormone insulin
cortisol
those seem to recover pretty
substantially within the first three to
four months some hormones take a little
bit longer testosterone levels and males
don't get they start certainly start
recovering within that three to four
month time range but they might not be
back to near totally normal baseline
levels until like five or six months for
a lot of people
same thing with leptin obviously leptin
is closely tied to how full your fat
cells are so certainly if you try to
stay super lean the leptin is just not
coming back for most people if if you
diet and then recover but you're this is
something I've always wondered about
leptin so it does seem the kind of maybe
govern set points to some degree and
it's based partially on what you're
eating partially on energy availability
and partially on the fullness of said
fat cells so I was wondering like if
let's say someone starts at 25 percent
body fat they cut to five percent
because you know they very aggressively
wanted to do a bodybuilding show and
started from a very very deep offseason
and then they want to like settle at
fifteen percent after the recovery do
those leptin levels get back to normal
because those fat cells so like 15% is
generally a pretty normal healthy body
comp but those fat cells are gonna be a
lot less full at 15% than 25% so like
does leptin like does recovery of leptin
happen if people don't get all the way
back up to the body comp or I guess down
back down to the body company started
with without having data in front of me
I certainly wouldn't expect it to to get
all the way straight back to baseline I
would expect it to be at a new baseline
because again those those fat cells are
in a very different state but I would
think that it should least be within a
what we would consider like a normal
reference range gotcha
whereas when they're when they're down
in prep level it will probably be
comfortably below the No
more reference range so I don't think
the goal should be to get leptin
necessarily back to its baseline value
because as you get very obese you can
drive those leptin levels through the
roof and I mean if you want to get those
levels when you're down at like 13
percent body fat good luck but I would
say that it's probably an advisable goal
to try to get back within the reference
range and what you might find is that
even though even though the leptin level
doesn't quite settle back at its highest
number especially if you start with a
decent amount of body fat you might find
that you know leptin is a little bit
lower but the things we associate with
leptin are still ret regulated very
normally just as leptin sensitivity
improves exactly yeah I would expect
that if you started with super inflated
leptin levels you probably had some
degree of leptin resistance in many
cases that makes sense so yeah that
that's a really good point of something
to keep in mind is that the goal doesn't
necessarily need to be to get every
aspect of your to retain every aspect of
what you did when you were at a
substantially higher body fat but now at
a lower one so like for instance let's
say you started out 25 percent body fat
like your example but strong as hell
right and you you dyed it down to 5
percent or whatever and you settle back
at 13 in the offseason you at 13 percent
is still gonna be a much smaller person
than you used to be at 25 you're not
gonna recover all your strength you know
so in in most cases and so that that's
something to keep in mind is that if
you're not interested in getting all the
way back to your starting weight you're
gonna have to make some concessions in
terms of how you view recovery but
generally speaking I would say as long
as you're allowing a somewhat generous
rate of weight regain to put you back at
a still decently lean but at least
sustainable body fat usually within six
months you should for most outcomes be
about where you're gonna be you know it
should be you shouldn't be thinking like
well over the next 18 months I'm gonna
start feeling normal if that's the case
you need to make some more concessions
and start eating
or you you should really try you should
aim to be feeling yourself again within
a few months and then essentially fully
recovered within six I think one thing
that is extremely unpredictable though I
don't want to spend a ton of time on it
but I've said it before the recovery of
a normal menstrual cycle is so difficult
when you look at the research the amount
of variability is really wild so there
was a case study the first author's last
name was Holliday and in that case study
the participant it took a full 71 weeks
to get back to I don't know if it was
the first menstrual cycle or when it was
a fully normal menstrual cycle but I
remembered like it took a full 71 weeks
to get the menstrual cycle at least
operating again and that was with a
competitor that did regain close to if
not all of their body weight I actually
think they regained a little bit more
than they lost during the prep there
there are also some some larger studies
in non physique athletes looking at like
dancers and various endurance athletes
with like menstrual disorders and even
when they do like nine 12 months 12
month interventions it's really hit or
miss about who's going to recover and
who isn't and there's even a study by
Chu at all C Hou in 2011 they kind of
took a really extreme approach with
exogenously on injections and
menstruation it was restored in only
seven of the ten subjects undergoing the
injections and it was restored in a span
of three - I'm sorry four to 32 weeks in
those seven that did have restoration so
what was that just left in injections or
left in injections along with over
feeding and some other sort of
intervention I would imagine
I'm not certain but I'd be shocked if
they didn't have at least some other
kind of intervention to make sure that
their diet and exercise habits were
conducive to rely k-- getting them at
least back to a somewhat appropriate
energy availability level
well I'd be stunned if that wasn't part
of the intervention I'd have to go back
and check but that would be a pretty
nonsensical intervention if they if they
gave them left in the injections and
then just said yeah but you can still
have totally disordered eating and run
eight hours a day so I would imagine
that there was at least some degree of
restriction over those aspects but in
any case to put it in a nutshell I was
having a discussion with Brandon Roberts
Peter fijian and Eric Helms and all you
know we were going back and forth about
like how long does it take to recover
and we're like I don't know man where
did you start how lean did you get how
much are you over feeding are you
willing to regain your weight how much
of it should you regain we're trying to
put together like a decent estimate on
the time and I think essentially we
reached the conclusion that it's like
time is not a good way to to approximate
that it really comes down to a
multifactorial approach after the
competition or after this dieting phase
you need to manage your training volume
you need to manage your energy
availability and you need to get back to
a sustainable body fat if all of those
are met all of those conditions are met
in a timely manner within the first you
know three four or five weeks after
competition you're at least moving in
those directions I would expect that you
know with a with a steady rate of weight
regain and immediately getting to a
decent training volume and a decent
energy availability status I would say
somewhere within three to six months you
should be feeling pretty alright okay
question for Gregg about training here
so looking for strength adaptations and
the question is is daily undulating
periodization within blocks the best
approach or high-frequency Norwegian
style training yes so the this is a
somewhat tough question to answer
because the two approaches aren't aren't
mutually beneficial so you know it's
kind of like what's best like apples or
bananas it's like they're two different
things so you can have a high-frequency
approach to train
that also utilizes daily undulating
periodization so it's hard to say one or
the other is better because there there
are two separate things that that can
can be integrated so I'm just gonna talk
about DUP itself and then training
frequency in general so in terms of how
how good and how useful DUP is in in
opposition to like a non DUP approach I
think a fair amount of that depends on
like how long do you have between right
now and when you're retesting your
strengths so what I mean by that is that
if you are if you're coming off say like
an offseason block of training and you
haven't been training that heavy for a
while and you want to hit the heaviest 1
rep max possible in six weeks then I
think that daily undulating training is
a pretty smart thing that one can do if
you're comparing that to say a more
linear approach where you're not also
going to include high-intensity training
every week and it's maybe like you know
two weeks at 70% two weeks at 80% in two
weeks at ninety percent so I I did a
review of the research on different
periodization approaches for stronger by
science maybe two years ago at this
point and in that review there was a
trend for I can't remember if it was
statistically significant or not I think
it was but if it was it was still not
like a super low p-value but there was
like a there was a tendency for daily
undulating approaches to do better than
linear approaches without like
undulating programming within the week
for for strength for most circumstances
but the the interesting thing to note is
like
most of the linear versus DUP studies
that have been done are fairly short
term so like 12 weeks or fewer and a lot
in like the eight ish week range there
were only a handful of studies that ran
longer than that so like I think a
couple used 16 weeks and maybe like one
was like 20 weeks long and in the longer
duration studies the DUP approach didn't
outperform the linear approach and the
the out performance of DUP over a linear
approach was the largest in the shortest
term studies overall so I think what's
going on there is that with DUP you're
generally having a heavy day a medium
day and a light day you can call them
strength power hypertrophy but I don't
know I don't particularly like that
terminology because that's often not
exactly what those three days correspond
with like what you'd be training on
those days but so anyway you have a
heavy a heavy day a medium day and a
light day and generally on that heavy
day you're gonna be going at least
eighty eighty-five percent of your max
so you're doing something pretty heavy
every week or at least fairly heavy
every week compared to a purely linear
approach without any within week
undulating elements if it's a six-week
study you may only be going over 80 85
percent for two weeks before testing
there's like two light weeks to medium
weeks two heavy weeks so you're in a
situation where you're comparing one
group that has done at least some heavy
training every week for six weeks versus
another group that has only gotten in
practice with heavy weights for two
weeks prior to testing so under those
circumstances I don't think it's all
that surprising that DUP does better for
the longer duration studies where you
know it's running sixteen weeks or
longer generally the way those studies
are set up is the linear group is
training fairly heavy for at least four
or five weeks prior to testing and so
they have plenty of time to develop
comfort with heavy weights
to build the skills that they need to
lift heavy and hit a good max and so you
know you have one group that's been
touching heavy weight every week for 16
weeks you have another group that has at
least been touching heavy weight every
week for four or five weeks doesn't
really seem like the dup approach leads
to bigger strength gains in that
circumstance so I kind of think to
circle back to to how I started
answering this question I think it
depends when when you're testing so
basically I think it's it's probably a
pretty good idea to get in at minimum
four to six weeks of training where you
know you're going at least over 80 85
percent of your max you'll be ready to
hit a good one rep max on unmeet day or
on test day and if you have six months
between now and your next competition
you don't necessarily need to implement
DUP and go heavy every single week for
the next six months to be ready to go
heavy at the competition you just have
more time to work with and you don't I
don't necessarily know that you get
anything out or you get any more out of
already going super heavy when you're
like four weeks or four months I should
say out from a meet so anyway I think I
think undulating approaches in general
can be good for a lot of lifters just
from just from a perspective of like not
burning them out a lot of people don't
necessarily like to train in the exact
same intensity range session after
session week after week it leads to
staleness it just isn't fun for a lot of
people and so I think I think a big
practical benefit of DUP or just some
undulating approach to your training is
just that you're you're cycling through
rep ranges and intensities and you're
you're doing something at least kind of
fresh session to session week to week
and so I think that can be more engaging
for a lot of lifters but just in terms
of peer
physiology I don't know that long-term
it offers you've that much of an
advantage unless it's just something
that your lifters really really like and
I think that lifter Preferences often
discounted but I think that in terms of
if you're gonna use DUP with someone
year-round the best rationale for it is
that's just what this lifter really
likes anyway so that that answers I hope
the DUP part of the question really
really good in the short-term not worse
in the long-term but probably doesn't
actually add you that much extra if you
have a long time between today and when
you're gonna test as long as you can get
in at least a good four to six weeks of
heavy training prior to when you play it
on Maxine then in terms of frequency I
think that I think that there's the
theoretical arguments to be made for
higher training frequencies I think when
you look at the literature so I did a
review on this for stronger by science
as well it seems that higher frequency
approaches in general tend to lead to
like not night and day faster strength
gains but slightly faster strength gains
than lower intensity approaches my
general assumption is that there's
probably some degree of diminishing
returns and that having a training
frequency of twice a week for each main
lift is probably a pretty decent amount
better than once per week not for
everyone but for most people three times
per week maybe slightly better than
twice per week but probably isn't a huge
deal and then I think you hit pretty big
diminishing returns after that point so
like I think two to three percent is the
sweet spot for most people in most lifts
on average but one thing that one thing
that I've seen not necessarily in the
research but just as someone who's
talked about high frequency training
has also talked to a lot of people who
have been you know training and
competing since the 80s when like lower
frequency approaches were a lot more
common is I think that I think frequency
is is maybe the most volatile training
variable that there is in terms of like
the major one so you know volume
intensity frequency I think of those
three frequency is the one that that is
the most volatile like for most people
if you dial up intensity a little bit
it's probably gonna be a little better
for strength gains for most people you
know as long as you're not just like you
know hitting ninety percent plus every
single week but you know on average over
time training at like 80 85 percent
probably going to be better for strength
gains than training at 70 percent over
time that's fairly predictable it's not
how it works for all people but that's
how it works for the vast majority of
people volume is kind of more of a like
an inverted you approach if you're just
doing one set per week for a major
movement you're probably gonna be a lot
better off doing five sets per week for
that major movement and if it gets
extreme and you're doing 30 sets per
week that's probably not great either
I think we're exactly that inverted U is
situated depends a lot on the individual
but that overall relationship is again
fairly predictable optimal volume for
some person might be 5 sets a week for
someone else it might be 15 but that
overall inverted u-shape fairly
predictable for most people most people
don't make their best strength gains on
super super low volume or ridiculously
high volume frequency on the other hand
is it's a [ __ ] crapshoot like so some
people really do do the best with a
frequency of once per week they do more
than that they start getting worn down
[ __ ] starts breaking like it's it's just
not good that is like some people they
move from
frequency of once per week - twice per
week in the wheels fall off I don't
think that's incredibly common but I've
seen it enough times that I don't think
it's like oh these people like the
entire rest of their program was [ __ ]
and that's what it was like some people
just can't handle that much frequency
period one challenging session per week
that's optimal for them I think two to
three works pretty well for a lot of
people but then on the higher frequency
end of things there's some people and
particularly like certain lifts for some
people where when they get up in like
the 4 to 5 times per week frequency
range or possibly even higher then it's
like takes off like a rocket ship you
know you add 50% or not 50% that's
insane you have like 50 pounds to a lift
in six weeks and it's like why did I
never try this before this high
frequency [ __ ] it's the best thing ever
and then if they go back to lower
frequency nothing happens and it's like
okay I'm married to the higher frequency
approach now this is just what really
really works well for me and then for
other people they dial up training
frequency more than three times per week
and the wheels just fall off they just
can't do it and I think sometimes that's
down to programming because you know if
you have a frequency of twice per week
you can go pretty hard in both of those
sessions for a particular lift and still
have plenty of time to recover you can't
necessarily go into high frequency
training with the same mindset if you
really really get after it for a lift
five times per week that's probably not
ideal like you're gonna need to lower
volume per session you're probably gonna
need to leave a few more reps in the
tank so I think for some people the
higher frequency stuff doesn't work
either because they don't know how to
modify things rolling into it or just
psychologically they don't want to do a
training session where they don't feel
like they really really push themselves
and they can't get in kind of like the
submaximal mindset that's necessary to
to make high like really high frequency
approaches work but I think some people
they do do everything right but they
they just they just can't handle it
but yeah so just to simplify in
restate a lot of what I just said I
think that like if you know nothing
about an individual and you're setting
up a training program for them the
frequency of once or twice per week for
deadlift two to three times per week for
squat two to three times per week for
bench I think that's a pretty decent
starting point for most people but I
don't think you can assume that
frequency is going peoples response to
frequency is going to be as predictable
as their response to volume and
intensity like some people they will
thrive with high frequency some people
are gonna crash and burn some people are
gonna make their best progress with
really low frequency so it's it's hard
to give a one-size-fits-all
recommendation like I said once or twice
per week for deadlift two to three for
squat and bench that's kind of like
normal ish enough that it works fairly
well for most people but when you start
experimenting with different frequencies
I would say probably throw expectations
out the window may do great may do
really poorly probably not going to be
incredibly predictable I think that's
important to that people at least are
encouraged to give it a shot and see
what they think oh yeah because with
high frequency training especially on
the bodybuilding side where there's a
million ways to do it
I feel like bodybuilding training it's
like god there's just so many different
approaches that have become popular over
the years when people try it aside from
their response to it I think one of the
things that also varies a lot is how
much people enjoy it and so like some
people love the idea that if their
training legs they're you know lower
body five days a week they can go in and
do an exercise or two legs and move on
do some chest do some back whatever
whereas some people really can't stand
the idea of not being on their sixth set
of legs and like crawling out of the gym
and there's a lot of different ways to
set up those training programs but an
important thing to consider is which of
those do you prefer like do you need to
feel like you really train the hell out
of a muscle group before you leave the
gym or are you comfortable with saying
cool I did
sets of back work and I'll be doing it
again tomorrow or the day after you know
yeah yeah I think I think that that is a
big thing as well in like I said I think
it it kind of depends on whether someone
can get into the submaximal mindset and
I could see that being a bigger problem
for bodybuilders on average than power
lifters yeah but yeah I mean some people
some people like higher frequency stuff
is the most psychologically liberating
thing because there used to say only
having one big squat day a week and they
need to get after it on that squat day
like they have to hit the numbers they
have written down volume has to be
pretty high so that they're gonna be
pretty worn down by the end of that
session and you know if that session
goes poorly you just have to like crawl
back into your hole and hope it goes
better next week and then you have like
a whole week to fret about it and stress
about it whereas like if it's if it's
your only time squatting that week like
that session [ __ ] matters and it
better go really really well or 150th of
you're squatting for the year right
exactly and if it goes poorly then you
have to wait an entire week to find out
like was that session just an aberration
or is this program going poorly yeah and
then that's you know a 25th of you're
squatting for the year that you're just
trying to figure out is this program
going well or not whereas with a higher
frequency approach like you can have bad
days you can have good days if the [ __ ]
really isn't going well and you're
training to lift four times in a week
you get those three or four bad workouts
back to back to back to back and you
find out within a calendar week that
like Oh something I'm doing is and isn't
really agreeing with me right now
and you don't have to you don't have to
stress about squat day next week for an
entire week and stress as much about
every session and then like on the flip
side I do think it's
high-frequency stuff can be stressful
for people who are who are like the
complete opposite of that
like like Eric mentioned if you're
someone who does want to be peeling
themselves up off the floor of the gym
and on the verge of death after a squat
session and that's the only way you know
how to train squat and that's the only
way you want to train squat like if you
tried another approach to squatting you
would just hated because that's that's
not a squad ad you goddamn it don't do
high frequency but you you can't do that
five days a week I was gonna say yeah
whichever way you go cuz I did that
previously in my life I damn it I hate
to admit this but I used to I hate to
admit the second part of this the first
part is I used to train each muscle
group once per week so I beat the hell
out of it I'm not embarrassed to admit
that I am embarrassed to admit that the
first time I tried high-frequency
training I still did it and so it was
like I trained the hell out of every
muscle group everyday and as you might
suspect it did not go particularly well
those are rough times yeah I mean I
think I think I think that's how it was
for a lot of people who tried higher
frequency stuff back in the day cuz I
get I mean at this day it's I feel like
there are different communities in the
fitness industry built around different
frequencies like there there are
definitely people who still advocate for
body parts splits and once per week
frequencies there's a large and I think
growing movement of people who are
big-time advocates for higher frequency
and like if you're interested in higher
frequency stuff you can seek out
information and there's there's folks
who will guide you through it and say
you know if you're coming to this off of
a lower frequency approach you know
probably shouldn't be going as close to
failure every said definitely shouldn't
be doing as many sets per workout for a
particular muscle group as you're
accustomed to like there's there's
pretty decent advice for easing into it
you go back like six or seven years
or even longer when when like the
hardcore orthodoxy was once per week and
maybe twice if you're a crazy
[ __ ] and if anything higher than
that you're gonna over train and die
like back then there wasn't that much
information out there about higher
frequency approaches and I think one of
the reasons there wasn't is like you
know everyone just trained each muscle
group once or twice a week and so you're
gonna try four times a week well you're
gonna train that muscle group the only
way you know how which is with a level
of volume and effort that was
appropriate for once per week and then
everyone just train themselves into the
ground so yeah I think I mean I did that
too like I think if you ask someone if
you ask people who experimented with
higher frequency approaches more than
about five years ago how they tried it
the first time I think a lot of us
probably did something similar yeah
all right next question for Eric from
mr. Andre what is your take on intuitive
eating given the fact that macro and
calorie counting is only possible since
the advances of science it seems like we
should have a built-in mechanism which
will increase hunger when our body
registers the necessity for muscle
growth yes I'm gonna keep my answer
pretty brief because intuitive eating is
not an area that I claim to have a great
deal of expertise in and I don't want to
fall into that trap of like building a
straw man being the hell out of it and
then having like the intuitive eating
crowd be like hey I don't think you get
it but based on the premise of the
question it sounds like macro and
calorie counting hasn't been a critical
part of human history shouldn't we have
mechanisms in place that will adjust our
appetite to an appropriate degree based
on what we need do you think that's a
fair characterization Greg yeah I think
that's pretty much what he's getting at
so in our current food environment
whether it's the way foods made or our
societal and kind of cultural responses
to food
it doesn't seem as though one can rely
purely on hunger cues alone to dictate
their caloric intake or maybe
theoretically you could but because of
different hedonic in cultural and
societal aspects of how we approach food
we just override the hell out of them
but in any case certainly you can tell
when you're hungry but I don't think
people are good at telling exactly how
hungry they are and tailoring their
intake perfectly to that some people are
quite good at it but when you look at
mathematically how easy it is to become
overweight or obese based on BMI data
across a billion different cultures on
the planet it seems like those built-in
mechanisms are not doing a great job of
keeping us perfectly titrated to energy
balance however tracking forever is not
a sustainable approach you know you you
don't want to be like oh I I used to
only eat clean foods but now I
discovered macros so I'm going to live
my entire life with a digital food scale
and a tracking app in my pocket that's
not a sustainable way to do things so
I'm more for this is a term I made up
with virtually no effort or thought so
let's not let's not hashtag it but
viewing it more as like habitual eating
rather than intuitive eating which
basically what I'm getting at is I think
it does benefit people who have some
interest in manipulating their diet to
do some pretty pretty detailed tracking
for some stretch of time so be like you
know what for the next 4 6 8 12 weeks I
am gonna track my food pretty well and
I'm gonna use a scale and I'm gonna
track my macros pretty diligently and
start to start to learn what portion
sizes look like what's swapping certain
foods in in substitutions what those
look like
I think you want to build up the skill
of macro tracking so that you can
transfer out into more habitual eating
habits now that doesn't mean you have to
eat the same thing every day but I think
a decent
goal for somebody who wants to keep an
eye on their diet and manipulate it
without really rigorous tracking I think
a goal would be to develop enough of a
skill set with some amount of tracking
that you can kind of mentally loosely
track when you're not tracking and the
the goal would be that essentially you
can become skilled enough to make some
some broad estimations and substitutions
within your normal base habitual diet
but also develop a comfort level with
knowing that your estimations and
substitutions don't have to be perfect
so part of that is a skill a skill set
and part of that is more of a
psychological status of being
comfortable with some degree of
uncertainty while largely being close
with your estimation and so what I'm
getting at is like you know Greg and I
are fortunate we get to go to a bunch of
really cool fitness conferences and
stuff with people that are really damn
good at body building and even if
they're not a competitive bodybuilder
they're they're clearly they know what
they're doing with their diet I mean
Greg how often do you sit down at a you
know a table full of speakers and
everyone pulls out their food scale
literally never I've never seen it we
were actually actually no no no that
happened one time at the fitness
eminating Kansas City one year Spencer
Nadal ski was prepping for his first
bodybuilding show and I don't know who
he hired to do his nutrition but I think
his like meal plan for the day had I
don't know X number of grams of bananas
like it was like a hundred grams of
banana I guess and he pulled out a food
scale and cut a banana in half and waded
out to make sure he got the appropriate
amount of banana and and he realized
after the fact that that was like way
too obsessive and anal and and I think a
lot of people have forgotten about it
but it became like a running joke for a
few years like not at his expense like
Spencer is a great guy and he's like
super good-natured so I think he thought
it was as funny as anyone else did
yes I can think of exactly one time that
someone pulled out a food scale to weigh
out the appropriate fraction of a banana
to consume but that's that's the only
time I've seen that happen and it was
out of character enough for that
environment that everyone thought it was
hilarious
yeah and in Spencer's defense honestly
if I was prepping and I was within 18
weeks of a show I would have done the
same thing
today oh yeah I mean he I felt really
bad for him that whole weekend because
we went to at the time Oklahoma Joe's
now Casey Joe's barbecue which is is
generally considered one of the best
barbecue joints in the country my hot
take is I think gates and LCS and Kansas
City are both better than Casey Joe's
but whatever that's neither here nor
there we went there and everyone else
was getting like ribs and brisket and
pulled pork and whatever else and
Spencer had a plate of just plain smoked
turkey and I mean like it totally makes
sense that he did that but you could
tell that he was dying a little bit
inside because it was really good
barbecue and that was that was the only
thing on the menu that he could eat yeah
it's it's tough man like with preso prep
is it kind of a whole different animal
like if you're seven weeks out from a
competition I'm not going to be like hey
you really need to develop develop a
more comfortable relationship with no
you just you gotta hit your metrics at
that point but but I will say that most
like most people that you consider like
a really high-level natural bodybuilder
in the evidence based world Greg and I
have dined with them sitting at tables
many times and no one reaches for the
scale they've basically all had enough
tracking experience that they now are in
a spot where they have a normal base
diet they kind of mentally make some
substitutions you can keep an eye on
things and kind of mentally track stuff
without having to get out the scale and
actually do really detailed macro
tracking so I think that is a good goal
for people but I think that a lot of
people if they
again I don't mean to create a straw man
if I am but if you're gonna say I'm
gonna go purely based on appetite and
just let my body do its thing I think
most people will tend to overeat
I think from the fact that that's not a
perfectly calibrated system and the fact
that there are hedonic and cultural
societal aspects of food I think most
people if they said I'm going to give no
thought to calories and just kind of let
my body do its thing I think most people
unless they eat a diet that's full of
almost exclusively low energy density
foods I think most people are going to
find that they overeat a little bit
unless they're one of those people who
never has an appetite and then they're
probably gonna under eat a little bit so
I I don't think it makes sense to
completely detach from some kind of
quantitative approach but I also don't
think people should be tracking for the
rest of their life build up the skill
set learn to do it sensibly be
comfortable with some degree of
estimation and just kind of work it in
one thing I would add is well like just
looping back to the question and like
what was explicitly asked so it did ask
about intuitive eating but specifically
it was asking when you're training hard
that should up regulate hunger so you'll
eat enough for muscle growth and for
some people that's the case but overall
when you so there's not that that much
research looking at the effects of
resistance training on appetite there
was a study that was just published this
month that was comparing high-intensity
like lower volume training to kind of
like moderate intensity like almost
bodybuilding style training which one
would assume would be the training that
would be more beneficial for muscle
growth and with that study found was
that the like moderate intensity like
bodybuilding style training actually
suppress appetite compared to nothing
and you will probably be maybe a little
hungry or the next day but like acutely
and what I meant to say before I got
slightly ahead of myself
so there's
much research on appetite regulation
with resistance training there is more
on appetite regulation with like
high-intensity interval training which
may may be comparable because it
probably works a lot of the same energy
systems and and maybe would have the
same effects and high-intensity interval
training pretty reliably suppresses
appetite for at least a couple hours so
I think that I think there's kind of two
questions one is like intuitive eating
in general and for that I think Eric
gave a really good answer then the
second one is like intuitive eating in
the context of getting hungry enough due
to exercise that your body will eat more
than it otherwise would to build muscle
and I think of anything the evidence
actually runs counter to that like high
intensity stuff generally causes some
degree of appetite suppression and one
of the reasons why if you look at like
long-term weight maintenance research if
you look at weight loss research you
tend to see like exercise might help a
little bit but it doesn't really make a
night-and-day difference for weight loss
seems like seems like nutrition is the
main thing going on here
but exercise is like super important for
long-term weight maintenance and one of
the primary reasons why is like contrary
to what one would expect like moderate
levels of exercise do actually cause
some degree of appetite suppression so
being totally sedentary makes you
hungrier than eating or than than doing
some level of exercise so I wouldn't if
you're trying to do intuitive eating for
gaining weight and building muscle I
wouldn't rely on on training to make you
hungry enough for that purpose and I'm
assuming given the fact that the person
is asking this question they they are
probably someone who does struggle
gaining weight and in like for whom that
wouldn't come naturally so I think that
if that's the case like it may not be a
bad idea to at least watch what you eat
to try to eat more because I want it I
wouldn't
trust resistance training to to do the
appetite work for you to to eat more if
that isn't something that you already
have experience with it coming naturally
to you yeah and I do want to highlight
the fact that when we look at that
exercise and appetite research there's a
big distinction between the acute
response in the hours following the bout
and any potential kind of makeup hunger
occurring after that acute phase and
there as you mentioned there's also when
you look there's a lot more cardio
related like aerobic low intensity
related literature than like high
intensity stuff when it comes to like
usually people are looking at from a
weight-loss perspective of do people
tend to replace the calories that they
burned and from that perspective there's
a ton of variability some people can
very comfortably use cardio as a fat
loss mechanism low intensity cardio some
people will almost perfectly replace the
energy that they consumed but you know
maybe not in the immediate meal after
but in the hunger ensuing later and some
people overcompensate some people do
overcompensate so there's so much
variability there but absolutely the
takeaway point is if you're relying on
some very reliable mechanism by which
high-intensity exercise is gonna use
hunger to tell you exactly how many
calories you need to optimize muscle
growth it's just probably not gonna work
that way
alright so Greg there's a couple
questions for you that are specifically
about different aspects of exercise
selection for a couple different
exercises and choosing variations and
where certain exercise variations might
apply so the first one is from honest
fitness and the question is what
exercise would you use for mechanical
tension / overload for the chest when
not doing the benchpress so honestly I
don't think bench press would be one of
my top exercises if someone was just
choosing exercises for growing the pecs
I mean obviously bench press is
important if you're a power lifter it's
literally a third of the sport but if
someone was just
hey man I want to grow my pecs what
exercises would you do benchpress
absolutely isn't a bad choice but I
think there are actually several
exercises that would be better options
so in terms of like flat pressing
exercises I think dumbbell bench would
probably be my go to the the main reason
I would choose choose that over the
bench press two reasons actually so one
range of motion can be longer with
dumbbell bench this probably wouldn't be
really important for people who aren't
rather barrel-chested but for someone
who especially benches with like a
moderate to wide grip and has like a
large ribcage benchpress is a partial
range of motion exercise for the pecs it
is a fairly long range of motion
exercise for the pecs but you could
certainly do more shoulder horizontal
abduction so one for for barrel-chested
people just folks with big rib cages
dumbbell bench allows a longer range of
motion which is probably going to be
beneficial for PEC growth and it's also
going to be more likely to be limited
specifically by PEC strength than the
bench press well so I think for a lot of
people bench presses are really good PEC
exercise but for some people like
they're just a way more tricep dominant
bench or even even with a fairly wide
grip they're triceps obviously their
pecs are still contributing but their
triceps can contribute very very heavily
to the bench press due to the way that
they can change like lateral forces that
would be something really confusing to
just explain vocally I wrote about it in
the bench guide on the website so if
you're interested in like the difference
in how bench press vs dumbbell bench can
affect the triceps and how much the
triceps can get into the movement
check out the bench guide I explained it
in there
but yeah so dumbbell bench is is going
to be way more likely to be limited by
the pecs you can also take the pecs
through a longer range of motion in all
likelihood because like the distance
between your hands isn't locked in space
and so yeah I think I think dumbbell
bench is probably a preferable exercise
for PEC growth to the barbell bench so
that would be high up on my list if you
want to do something with a barbell
I think low incline press is a really
really good option it helps you get a
slightly longer range motion probably
helps integrate your upper pecs a little
bit more if you're still like arching
your back a little bit and pulling your
shoulder blades together like if you're
coming to this from some sort of
powerlifting background like a low
incline bench
basically gets you to a pretty similar
technique as like a flat bench that a
bodybuilder would perform so it lets you
accomplish the same basic thing without
having to get out of the bench setup
that you prefer quick question when you
say a low angle for the incline how low
are we talking 30 at most like 15 to 20
percent is ideal okay
why I was just curious I thought it
listener might want to know and I yeah
fair enough
I'm not against like a regular 45 degree
incline but like I've done a fair amount
of incline it's a exercise I tend to
like and just the the degree to which
you're getting your pecs into it versus
front delts I really think that low
incline like 15 to 30 degrees is a
better option so I will admit my bias
that probably contributed to my asking I
do tend to go a little bit higher than
most mm-hmm so not even like I think
there's like the typical kind of like 45
degree I think is probably the setting a
lot of people go with mm-hmm
I go a little higher than that but I
also do it unilaterally and really focus
in on
getting the pec in the position I want
it I kind of maneuver my body like a
circus dumbbell press almost yeah and
the reason is if I do lower angles for
me I usually do my incline pressing in
conjunction with another flat PEC
movement uh-huh so I like to really
really really focus in on that higher
portion of the chest so I was just
curious oh man if I go even 45 degrees
but certainly over 45 degrees I just
it's just all front front front delt
yeah I don't get that fair enough
to each their own to each their own but
yeah so I would generally recommend if
you want to mess around with a barbell
probably low incline bench or just
incline bench
[ __ ] play around with the angles and
see what feels best for you
incline dumbbell also fantastic
I mean dumbbell bench dumbbell incline
those would probably be my to go twos
for compound exercises and then barbell
incline is like a third option and then
for for other exercises like the PEC
deck is great the PEC deck is is one a
good PEC deck and like a good pullover
machine are my two favorite machines if
I if I go train it like another gym and
I scouted out and they have a good
pullover and a good PEC deck
I'm happy those are also that the two
exercises that I feel like characterize
like 1991 bodybuilding like you're on
the PEC deck and you're on the damn
pullover and you're killing it well
that's when it peaked they knew what
they were doing
so PEC deck is great the the what's it
called the cam like the thing that the
like wire or like the strap is going
around is shaped somewhat oblong ly so
it helps match the strength curve of
your PEC it's like with flies obviously
they're hard at the bottom and super
super easy at the top and the way a PEC
deck works like a just because it's
machine resistance and and be like the
shape of the cam it can help match the
the strength curve of your pecs a little
bit better so like flies are fine but
PEC deck is just a better version of a
fly in my opinion and then as an
exercise that that I think a lot of
people don't think about but that I
think you probably shouldn't sleep on is
extended range of motion push-ups I
think are really really good I think a
lot of times like eventually most people
get strong enough that they can't get
too much out of push-ups anymore just
because of like if you're well I
wouldn't say a lot of people but if
you're bingeing like over double
bodyweight it's kind of hard to make
push-ups hard like you you can do some
work with band resistance and I think
band resisted push-ups are great for
most people but for like newer lifters
and for people who bench I would say
below like one and a half times
bodyweight extended range of motion
push-ups are awesome like you just get
if you're in a gym with bumper plates
you can just get like some bumper plate
45s and still go all the way down until
your chest touches the floor and it's
still just a damn push-up but the range
of motion is slightly longer I think
those are awesome like if I if I want to
do like a burn out set at the end of a
chest day if I'm just like growing out
and not doing powerlifting training
extended range of motion push-ups I find
her a great burnout for me and a great
like primary exercise for people with
slightly lower bench presses big-time
now what would would you have anything
to add Trek's like are there any chest
exercises that you just love that I
didn't touch on no I mean so my bench
press is interesting because I bench
with a very flat back and so I think
compared to most people my my flat
barbell bench is extremely PEC dominant
so I get a whole bunch of growth from
that but I know they're asking if you're
not doing the bench press I do a lot of
flat dumbbell I do a lot of incline
dumbbell I have not been doing
a lot of PEC deck lately cuz I struggle
to find a good machine for it you don't
see him as much as you used to one thing
that I do really like there's a cable
machine that's made by I think is it
life motion or life fitness or something
they have a whole series of machines
that are very cable driven but they're
still set up as if they're like a
standalone machine it's not just like a
random pulley in the middle of the gym
but they have a nice flat chest press
that you can do flies on that I love so
if I am gonna do a PEC deck or a fly
related movement I do like it to be
something with either a cable or like a
cam pulley because I think with
dumbbells trying to do like a dumbbell
fly variation there's just a huge
portion in that range of motion where
I'm I don't have much going on yeah it's
just completely wasted yeah so I think
if you are gonna go the route with any
kind of flies first of all make sure
you're really every now and then my
shoulders get upset if I do too much
flying so maybe keep an eye out for that
and try to find a nice machine that you
feel like you're actually working
through the range of motion now there
was another question about exercise
selection somewhat but the question was
do weighted thrusts help out on the
squat much yeah so maybe I mean so
here's my opinion on hip thrusts I think
that there are really really good
exercise for glute hypertrophy like some
form of squat some form of deadlift and
hip thrusts those would be like probably
my top three for glute hypertrophy so I
think they can help the squat insofar as
growing the glutes kind of you know
forming more contractile tissue in one
of the primary movers of the squat it's
probably gonna help the squad so I think
it can be beneficial just from a glute
hypertrophy perspective but probably
doesn't have that much just great direct
carry over in terms of like the range of
motion that hip thrusts are really
really training hard versus the range of
motion where the hip extensors are
really really challenged in the squat so
you tend to see a force output so like
when the bar starts decelerating you
tend to see force output being the
lowest in the squat at or slightly above
parallel and then you tend to see what
most people think of as the sticking
point would like the point of minimum
bar velocity a little bit higher than
that and so in that position generally
you're still in a pretty fair amount of
hip flexion and if you've ever done a
heavy hip thrust like you probably would
have felt this it's not that hard to get
the bar off the floor in a hip thrust
but the movement gets pretty hard like
right at lockout so I don't think it's
doing much to train like the specific
hip flexion range of motion where like
hip extension is going to be challenged
the most in the squat so I think it can
help the squat by helping you get a
bigger booty and then the bigger booty
can then be trained to develop strength
through that particular range of motion
and that's good
but in terms of direct carryover I don't
think there's a ton of direct carryover
from hip thrust to squats I do however
think hip thrusts can be pretty helpful
for the deadlift especially for people
who have a higher than normal sticking
point so normal sticking point and I'm
mostly thinking about conventional
deadlift here although I guess it could
apply to sumo as well if you're doing
like wider stands hip thrusts this is
just not something I've ever
experimented with much because I've
never had lockout issue sumo but for for
a conventional deadlift a lot of times
like people are gonna miss like
low-to-mid shin like either they fail at
the floor like they can get the bar off
the floor but fail pretty well below
their knees but here I'm thinking about
people who fail either like maybe just
slightly below knee height too
any point above knee height I think hip
thrusts do help a lot at training
deadlift lockout strength and of course
just growing a bigger booty to help with
the entire deadlift but but I do think
they're like specifically helpful for
training the glutes and the hip
extensors to be strong through that
range of motion so for people who do
tend to miss deadlifts in the top half
of the range of motion I think that that
weighted hip thrusts are indirectly
helpful again from just helping their
booty get bigger but also directly
helpful by like helping to improve
strength through that range of motion so
I think it can help both lifts but it's
probably for most people going to help
deadlift more than squat directly you
know I think this is actually the the
most times we've used the specific term
booty on a single episode that's a big
deal yeah I am I was doing some some SEO
research and seems like if you're in the
fitness space you got to be talking
about booties and I haven't found a
natural point to work in the phrase
pitch gang yet but but that's that's one
that we should probably work on
targeting in future episodes is that a
word that people actually use it's like
it's a pretty popular hashtag on
Instagram it's just like gang peach gang
yeah okay I mean I get it I understand
that there's no booty shots yeah anyway
so we got one more question Erik and I
are both going to answer and this is the
one that's gonna bring us home so Joey
at home asks how much evidence and
research would it take for you to
implement new findings into your own
practice one study with a large effect
size or multiple replicated studies how
much how much research do you need to
try something out either with yourself
or with your clients so I'll start and
and then certainly Greg you can chime in
with probably a violently different
approach
put me down as you like to do so my
viewpoint on this I think I always felt
the same way but I struggled to
visualize it until I wrote my first
meta-analysis now whenever I look at a
body of research my brain sees it as a
funnel plot and so the question is do
you care about a single study with a
large effect size or multiple replicated
studies what I would like to see if you
the reason I bring up a funnel plot is
what you'll find in research with small
samples is looking at the same
intervention it's not particularly rare
to wildly overestimate the size of the
effect it's also it should be equally
not rare to completely underestimate the
size of the effect so if you tell me
like hey this is the first study on a
topic there were seven people in each
group and the effect size look pretty
big I'd say cool but let's wait and see
you know if we do a bigger study is the
effect size
similarly really big or did we find that
the effect size is approximately zero
and then the next small study finds that
the effect size was negative big you
know and then we start to see like okay
the big sample size we heard the big
effect size we saw in one small study it
was probably just sampling error
sometimes with small groups of people
really weird things happen but they
should happen equally in the positive
and the negative direction now another
thing that you you should look at or
that I look at with a body of literature
is assuming all the studies were done in
a fairly similar way with equally
rigorous testing procedures in place if
all the small studies show a big effect
and the big studies show basically no
effect or a very minimal one I'm gonna
lean toward the big studies because
they're a little bit less prone to these
really volatile responses that we see in
super small samples so to answer the
question one one little study with a
large effect size is not enough to get
me super excited it's enough to get me
interested or there's
another similar situation where like all
of the really well controlled studies
don't show much and all of the more
poorly controlled studies show large
effects in one direction or the other
exactly yeah so that that's why I put
that caveat assuming they were all done
equally well yeah yeah but but that's an
assumption that's never true but in any
case it's a great point if you're
looking at the studies you want to say
how does the sample size seem to affect
the result how does the quality of the
study affect the result and then you can
start making some inferences but if it's
a brand new body of research I will
concede if there's like two studies out
on a topic they're done equally well
they're both pretty small samples that's
pretty much how this goes in our field
you get a couple small sample studies
out and you say wow there it appears
that there's either somewhere between no
harm and a huge benefit and this is very
easy to implement yeah I might be likely
to just give it a shot on my own see
what happens again in many cases what
we're looking at is something where the
stakes are low it's like this could be a
really you know high reward but let's
say this is no better than normal then
really no harm done so that's kind of
how I approach it is what's the risk
what's the potential benefit and then
you kind of filter that through what's
the quality of the evidence so I I agree
with all of that I think that the issue
of the stakes is is an important thing
to keep in mind so for example a recent
study relatively small found that doing
like low intensity static stretching
between sets of a given exercise helps
improve hypertrophy so you know you're
doing some dumbbell bench you do a set
and then during like between that set
and the next set you do some fairly
light stretching for your pecs and that
increased muscle growth relative to just
resting between sets that's something
that you know doesn't take much
to implement most people are going to be
resting between sets like it's not going
to be hugely inconvenient unless someone
traditionally just does like huge
circuit training type stuff so it's easy
to implement if anything there may be
ancillary benefits to it like it's gonna
keep you focused on doing something
physical in the gym and not just like
checking your phone and kind of zoning
out between sets so you know maybe it's
beneficial doesn't really seem like
there's much of a downside so you know I
see a small study it's statistically
significant I think the effect size was
moderate like it didn't make a night
night and day difference but stakes are
incredibly low really easy to implement
like sure I don't really need to see a
second study on that cuz like if it's
wrong like who cares it's not gonna be
bad you know versus if I saw a similar
type deal with a new supplement then you
know you have several other layers you
need to get through so someone's gonna
need to pay money for that so you know
is it worth it to potentially recommend
someone buy something that could end up
worthless and then they just wasted
their money there's issues with
supplement purity and maybe being spiked
with stuff that could make people fail a
drug test so would you necessarily
recommend a supplement that you know
could have unintended downsides for
someone that that there's not like a
robust body of research showing they're
like yes this is really really good
stuff that you should recommend so like
the stakes are a little bit different
there so you could have the same level
of evidence for both of those things and
I'd be more likely to recommend the you
know the the light stretching between
sets than the new mystery supplement
because the stakes are slightly
different one other thing that I would
kind of throw into the mix though is so
like I read research and write about
research professionally like that's I do
still coach but like the research side
of things is
mostly what pays my bills these days but
I'm still I am still like very much a
bro at heart like that's that's what got
me obsessed enough with this stuff to
get into it as a profession in the first
place
and so another like filter for me is
like does it kind of match Jim wisdom if
there's like a practice that has never
been studied before and the first study
comes out and there's like a a moderate
effect in favor of the stuff that like
strong inject people have been saying
for 20 years my bias is kind of like
well okay like that's probably legit if
it's the opposite and it's like all of
the big and strong people have been
saying the opposite of what this study
found for the past 20-30 years I'm
really really gonna want to wait till
that finding gets replicated because
it's absolutely not that Jim wisdom is a
hundred percent infallible it's
definitely not like it is wrong from
time to time but generally if I see
research matching practice I'm like okay
I am going to give this research a
little more rope and assume that it's
right if I see research contradicting
practice then I'm like you know if it's
just the first study I'm not gonna say
all of the practice that people have
been doing for the last few decades is
wrong and this research is right I'm
also not gonna say this researches is
wrong and biased and like funded by big
whatever I don't like and that practice
is right in that case it's more like
okay I am gonna I am gonna need to wait
and see more research before you know
throwing out twenty years of Jim wisdom
so whether or not the findings of the
research match the stuff that people who
seem to know what they're talking about
have been previously saying like that's
that's another filter for me and I think
a lot of times in those scenarios where
there's a study that comes out that like
flies in the face of conventional wisdom
a lot of times you can just look at the
study really take it and start to
speculate about what aspects of the duck
the design might have caused that
yeah like it's it's typically not like
wow they brought in a huge sample of
super well trained guys controlled
everything and everything we've been
doing is wrong
you know there's usually some
methodological considerations where you
can start to figure out like okay here
are some plausible explanations how the
conventional Jim wisdom has a grain of
truth to it but this study failed to
show that particular concept yeah yeah
for sure I mean in in the the big big
missus furred for Jim wisdom type stuff
I think it's often stuff that's like
kind of trivial so for example like
eating tilapia thins the skin like ya
know it probably doesn't but someone's
eating tilapia before a bodybuilding
show unless they're allergic to tilapia
like that's not gonna hurt them so like
you know it's it's often stuff like that
that is found to really be unimportant
an example from the training side of
things is like every lifter in every
sport coach and every like weight coach
or whatever twenty years ago if you
attempted to do anything physical
whether that be run whether that be lift
weights
whether that be wipe your butt without
doing like 30 minutes of calisthenics
and like stretching every muscle in your
body they would say what are you doing
you're gonna die and get hurt and kill
yourself and like now we know especially
like the static static stretching side
of things like yeah probably doesn't
matter probably not gonna do anything
good for you
probably not gonna do anything bad for
you assuming you're not doing super
intense static stretching and then you
two seconds later doing a maximum
vertical jump like it if it's part of a
warm-up and you do a bunch of static
stretching like by the end of the rest
of the warm-up stuff you do that static
stretching has probably had no effect
whatsoever it's like it's kind of a
waste of time but ultimately it's
trivial because it's not helping people
but it's also not hurting hurting people
and now like research contradicts that
pretty strongly like that you should do
a bunch of static stretching before
exercise so like
that's another example where it's
trivial like it wasn't negatively
affecting people so yeah I I tend to
think that it's either something like
that where like the Jim wisdom may not
be helping people but it's not really
hurting them either or it's what Eric
mentioned where you know it could have
to do with some details of the
population used or how the study was set
up all right well I think that does it
for this this week's episode like I said
next week we got a great episode coming
a really cool interview with Alex collie
re Turner really nice episode lined up
so thanks as always for joining us and
we will see you next week
and if you're interested in getting your
questions answered on a Q&A episode of
the stronger by science podcast you can
fill out our google form the URL for
that is tiny dot CC slash SBS QA all
lowercase that will be linked underneath
this episode or we specifically used a
URL shortener so it would be easy for
people to type in after they hear this
so again that is tiny dot CC slash SBS
QA all lowercase alright we'll see you
next time thanks for listening to the
stronger by science podcast now Greg and
I are not experts in medicine or health
or really anything else for that matter
so before you make any changes to your
diet and exercise habits make sure you
check with a doctor or another health
care professional if you enjoyed this
podcast and you'd like to support it
visit stronger by science comm to check
out the products and services that we
offer thanks for listening and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you